-Our next guest
is a very talented actor
you know from shows
such as "Private Practice"
and films like "Rent"
and "The Best Man" franchise.
He stars in "All American,"
which airs Monday nights
on the CW.
Let's take a look.
-My dad is gone.
-♪ Gone, gone ♪
-Anyway, I'm sorry this message
got way too long.
But, uh, like you, I had
some things I needed to say,
and, uh --
and I'm glad I did it.
Um, I love you, Spencer James,
and I always will.
You are my all American.
So, I know you said
you needed some time.
Um, I'm here
whenever you're ready
uh, because, you know,
you and me,
we got all the time
in the world.
-Please welcome back to the show
Taye Diggs, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-All right, thank you, sir.
-Welcome back!
-Yes.
Real quick.
Have y'all seen his stand-up?
-Okay.
-His -- yo.
-Very kind.
-It is so good, I saw it twice.
-Oh, wow!
-I saw it twice.
And I don't see
white boys twice.
I saw it twice,
so it's good stuff.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Double white boy.
-Yeah, man.
-That is -- oh!
This is --
Thank you for saying that.
That is very flattering.
-I was very impressed.
-So this is, you know,
for people who aren't
engaged with the show
and haven't seen it,
this was the end
of your character's arc.
This is five years
playing a football coach.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-A very shocking ending
to your character arc.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Did you enjoy playing
a high school football coach?
-I had a ball.
I had a ball.
It really helped --
I have a 13-year-old son
who is an athlete,
so I was able to kind of use
what I was doing at work with my
son at his games and whatnot.
So, it was a life-changing role.
I'm very thankful.
-When you were 13, were you
athletic or were you..,?
-I was athletic.
I wasn't an athlete.
-Gotcha.
-Yes.
-Because you already knew,
at that point,
theater was your path?
-Yes, yes.
Because I was not an athlete.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
But we have a photo.
-You tell us what age
this is of Taye Diggs.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's the age nerd.
-Yeah.
-That's what I've heard, yeah.
-I would say, like,
there's nobody --
If you use one of those apps
that guesses what you're gonna
look like as an adult, no one
guessed Taye Diggs on this.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-This never led to that.
And any A.I. ever would have
predicted that.
-That's why I was
into music theater, yes.
-So, you went to Syracuse,
and you started doing
music theater there.
-Yes.
And then -- is it,
You get a job at Tokyo Disney.
-Okay, we're going there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So is that right out of college?
-That was --
Actually, it's weird.
I -- I had already done
a Broadway show.
-Okay.
-And then a friend of mine
had come back from Tokyo Disney
and said
that he had a great time.
I hadn't traveled.
So I said, "I'm gonna take
some time off and go over there
and have an experience."
And it was amazing.
It was amazing.
Then I came back,
and then I got "Rent," so...
-Which is the life-changer.
-Yes, yes.
Game-changer,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
-Obviously, you know, "Rent"
is an incredible accomplishment.
What were you doing
at Tokyo Disney?
[ Laughter ]
-We want to go back?
Okay.
Uh, I was --
I was the host of a show
called "Sebastian's
Caribbean Carnival."
-Okay.
-Yes.
-Sebastian from
"The Little Mermaid."
-Yes, "The Little Mermaid."
-Yep.
-So, it was me,
and it was the crab.
[ Laughter ]
And then all of the --
And then,
Mickey and Minnie were there,
which was cool.
-Well, that's a coincidence.
-Yeah, yeah, it was great.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I sang,
and I had bananas on my arms.
-Uh-huh.
-And a straw hat.
And it was --
it was tons of fun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
How many shows a day
were you doing?
-It was, um...
five.
Five shows a day.
-That does not seem like --
you were earning it.
-100%.
100%. Yeah.
And we made a good wage,
but I learned the language
and went to the temples.
I climbed Mount Fuji,
which was cool.
-Well, there you go.
That's an incredible experience.
-It was great.
-And now, you know, I do think,
you know, it's really important
for actors to do experiences
like that.
-Yes.
-Because I'm assuming "Rent"
was also incredibly taxing,
but it probably helps
to do something --
-Oh, 100%.
Yeah,
soap operas and theme park.
Nothing is more difficult.
-Yeah, I believe it.
-I was on a soap opera,
and the amount of material
you have to learn in a day
is ridiculous.
So, it was a muscle
that I developed
and used later on in life.
-So, post-"Rent" --
obviously is
a Broadway sensation --
and then your first film
is "Stella,"
"How Stella
Got Her Groove Back."
-Yes, yes.
-Which I just saw.
It was Valentine's Day
this week.
It was on a list of like --
-Was it?
-The best 40.
I saw it.
One of the best 40 romantic
comedies of all time.
-For real?
-Yeah.
-Yes!
I always wanted to make a list.
-There you go --
you made the list.
-Yes!
I made the list.
-And so that --
What was that transition like?
Because now you've done
soap operas, theme parks,
you've done Broadway.
Is film easy or hard?
-It was --
Well, let me --
I was very confident
leaving college, right?
I felt like I knew, you know,
what I was supposed to do.
So, I moved
straight to New York,
and my first job
was a host at Pizzeria Uno.
And my other two hostesses,
when we were talking about
what we did
and what we were gonna do,
I said I was gonna be an actor,
and they scoffed.
And I said,
"You think I'm playing.
Give me a year,
and I'll either be in a movie,
have my own TV show,
or be on Broadway."
And in six months,
I was on Broadway.
So, when "Stella" came,
I was like, "Okay, cool.
I wish it had been a little
earlier, but..."
You know what I mean?
So, I was ready.
-I bet those two people
you worked with
were happy when it happened.
[ Laughter ]
They were like, if he gets
two out of three in a year,
we're never gonna
want to talk to him again.
-I told them.
Seven pieces.
-And was that a film while you
were making it, were you like,
"Oh, this is gonna be something
that people are gonna
respond to,
that's going to endure?"
-I'm so embarrassed.
I didn't know how
the whole industry worked.
So, you know,
I grew up reading "Us" magazine
and seeing the paparazzi.
The first day I came home
from the movie,
I thought that there
were gonna be television cameras
in my apartment.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Where is everybody?"
I didn't realize that the movie
hadn't even come out.
-You had a voicemail
from your Pizzeria Uno
being like,
"You're late for your shift."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly!
Exactly!
Nobody knew!
Nobody knew.
-Another film you made,
"The Best Man,"
which became a franchise
and now a show
over on Peacock...
[ Applause ]
-Thank you, guys. Thank you.
Yeah.
-And now that also must be
a special thing not only to make
something that people
still care about,
but to be able to keep
going back and doing it
with the same group of people.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I feel very, very lucky.
These people, the actors
and actresses from "Best Man,"
they're family.
We all kind of started
at the same time.
And to be able to grow
with each other on --
in such a piece is great.
-Wow.
-We've all seen each other
go through, you know, trials
and tribulation and breakups
and families and divorces.
And it's really great.
It's comforting.
-Yeah, it also is a nice
parallel, I guess,
because, of course, that's
what's happening in those films.
You're just watching them
grow up, characters.
And knowing the same
is happening in real life.
-So it was easy.
It was easy.
We all thought it would be
the last, but it's good.
I watched it, and it's good.
And so who knows?
-Yeah.
Well, there's no reason
to close the door.
Hey, what a delight
to have you back here.
-My man.
-Really, really, really
always appreciate seeing you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, sir.
-Taye Diggs, everybody!
"All American" airs
Monday nights at 8:00 p.m.
on the CW. Right back
with more "Late Night."